[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens ils sont un peu
chers je trouve c'est tout le reste ça
va
ouais bah y'en a beaucoup ces fréquences
et il y en a partout il faudra qu'ils
soient là toute la nuit
aussi je serai bien ou du manque encore
certaines lignes mais ça se trouve c'est
ans est mis en place
votre jambon square au cas contraire ils
en pensent quoi suce-moi frangins vous
rendre twitter
tout le monde se battait canada apprend
ça mais je le reconnais mais je sais pas
on s'en fout qu'est ce que vous pensez
des transports en commun parisiens
alors moi je les prends pas souvent mais
j'étais j'habitais en province jusqu'à
jusqu'en 2003 et donc j'ai déménagé pour
prendre ma retraite en région parisienne
et je trouve absolument géniale de
prendre le train ne pas voir sa voiture
et tout moi je trouve ça formidable et
votre soeur bonsoir pardon votre soeur
la soeur effet de serre et désolé j'ai
grandi en banlieue dans la galère prend
vrai vrai j'ai galéré
qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun parisiens je connais je pense
toutes les stations de métro les
enchères pas de nouvelles mais
pratiquement tout est votre est il en
pense quoi
mon frère
les cocos sabich mon frère je me regarde
les geôles m et c'est pour ça que je
veux pas en changer
je vous fait vivre et c'est vrai je le
regarde je suis mort deux fois qu'est ce
que vous pensez transports en commun de
paris et je pense que c'est un gros
bazar un très très gros bazar les gens
sont entrés et la réorganisation totale
pour tous et plus propre non papa poids
et c'est très cher pour ce que c'est du
vote frais ils en pensent quoi mettre
bas mon frère alors vous êtes qui vous
tombe de francs maçons de merde
[Musique]